je vous en prie
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
arrivé Marseille bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous Sénator des
Hauts-de-Seine président du groupe Union
centriste ici au Sénat président de
l'UDA on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet de westfrance bonjour
Stéphane bonjour bonjour
et le Sénat a donc examiné hier en
commission la réforme des retraites à
voter ses amendements est-ce que vous
pensez que le texte final sera voté en
séance est-ce que vous pensez que
l'examen pour aller jusqu'au bout
j'espère bien j'espère bien on veut
montrer la différence avec l'Assemblée
nationale c'est assez paradoxal qu'une
assemblée parlementaire s'organise
j'allais dire presque scientifiquement
pour s'effacer je veux dire pas tous les
députés vous avez remarqué vous voyez à
peu près à qui je suis allusion bon un
spectacle affligent mais surtout
institutionnellement cet assemblée qui
dans la Constitution à la prééminence
puisqu'elle a le dernier mot
c'est organisé pour s'effacer et pour ne
pas débattre pour ne pas travailler pour
ne pas voter c'est quand même assez
paradoxal surtout que ceux qui ont
organisé si je puis dire cette situation
sont ceux qui sont pardon des adeptes de
la démocratie pétitionnelle et qui exige
le retour de la démocratie et de la
démographie si en Afghanistan en Iran en
Ukraine
ont mis à la démocratie et à la
démocratie parlementaire
en tous les cas
on est dans un pays
qui a des règles institutionnelles le
texte un texte important il concerne
chaque Français et
l'assemblée si je puis dire à passer son
tour donc maintenant
elle a organisé si je puis dire la mise
en majesté en responsabilité du Sénat et
nous nous avons une responsabilité parce
que c'est notre mission
parlementaire que d'aller jusqu'au bout
et de sortir si je puis dire par un vote
le texte
au bout c'est voter les 14 les cartes
examinés voter les 14 articles du texte
allez jusqu'au bout du texte mais est-ce
que le fait le simple fait d'aller au
moins jusqu'à l'article 7 qui est l'acné
de cette réforme sur l'âge légal de
départ et ce que n'a pas fait
l'assemblée est-ce qu'elle est au moins
jusqu'à l'article 7 et le débattre
publiquement ce serait pas déjà une
victoire entre guillemets pour le Sénat
par rapport à l'assemblée je pose pas ce
genre de question sur les autres textes
je veux dire il y a des textes à
débattre il y a ce que le gouvernement
propose il y a ce que nous proposons en
tant que parlementaire les propositions
de loi notre rôle c'est d'examiner
l'ensemble du texte ça n'a pas de sens
de dire tiens on va manger seulement une
partie des choses non il y a un texte il
a une une globalement vous entendez la
gauche la gauche dit oui on fera en
sorte que l'article 7 soit examiné
contrairement à l'Assemblée parce qu'on
veut qu'il y a un vote au Sénat mais pas
forcément on veut pas forcément qu'il y
a un vote sur l'ensemble du texte vous
créez une forme d'obstruction de la part
de la gauche sénatoriale
on verra jusqu'à présent elle s'est pas
manifestée on verra dans les jours qui
viennent moi je regrette un peu cette
situation de
d'avoir une vision partielle
des textes
nous nous ne sommes pas élus pour
travailler quelques articles ECE ou
c'est nous enfin ça veut dire que vous
la majorité sénatoriale et la présidence
utilisera tous les moyens réglementaires
et tous les moyens du Règlement du Sénat
pour arriver au bout de l'examen parce
qu'il y a des moyens pour accélérer la
discussion vous souhaitez que ce soit
exactement soit employés vous imaginez
que il y a un débat où d'un côté il y a
un refus de l'obstacle si je puis dire
qu'on fasse tout pour pas parler et que
nous on soit passif en disant ah bah non
on va attendre parce qu'ils ont décidé
qu'on attendait non je veux dire si la
gauche décide de pas vouloir
mener son travail à bien c'est à dire
examiner le texte ben nous on emploie
les moyens du règlement juste pour info
pour il y a plus de 2200 amendements qui
ont été déposés est-ce que ça ça vous
paraît ça vous paraît beaucoup c'est
tout à fait raisonnable
en fait le groupe comédie je crois qu'il
a pas encore déposé quelque chose me dit
qu'il devrait y en avoir un petit peu
plus loin sur le fond le texte a été
examiné hier en commission il y a eu des
amendements qui ont été adoptés on va y
revenir dans le détail mais est-ce que
ce qui a été adopté hier en commission
vous convient est-ce qu'il y a des
points de divergence avec les
républicains écoutez on a abordé le
texte avec d'abord beaucoup de travail
parce que comme vous l'avez dit
l'assemblée finalement n'a examiné une
chose c'était le rond-point des
carrières longues on a tourné autour
pendant des semaines on n'a pas été plus
loin donc en clair
presque l'essentiel de tout toute la
j'allais dire tout le texte
n'a pas été étudié puisqu'il y a en gros
que les carrières longues on s'est
arrêté quasiment à ça mais j'allais dire
vous avez vu mon collègue ça varie vient
de vous l'expliquer avec beaucoup de
talents
la situation des femmes des seniors etc
etc la pénibilité les carrières les
carrières longues etc bon il y a en
dehors des carences rien d'autre n'a été
travaillé donc j'allais dire il nous
appartient de travailler le texte mais
un mot sur les carrières puisque vous y
venez parce que les carrières longues
rien n'a été adopté hier par la
commission qui laisse ça en débat au
Sénat qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez vous
par exemple les républicains à
l'Assemblée et le groupe horizon à
l'Assemblée souhaite que aucun français
dans un dispositif de carrière longue ne
travaille plus de 43 ans est-ce que
c'est aussi votre souhait
moi j'ai beaucoup de sympathie d'amitié
pour les républicains en travaillant
ensemble mais ce qu'ils disent c'est une
chose qu'on dit nous c'est autre chose
donc on trouve des compromis ensemble
donc d'abord
je crois que comme nous on souhaite
d'abord la réforme garde son sens parce
que s'il y a une réforme c'est qu'il y a
du déficit et donc il y a un besoin de
financement donc après ce qui a été fait
à l'Assemblée nationale
ça a coûté cher donc il faut faire très
attention parce que sinon on va nous
dire pourquoi vous faites une réformète
qui n'a pas qui n'atteint pas son
objectif c'est à dire de de garantir la
soutenabilité du dispositif retraite
donc ça c'est le premier point mais
juste ça veut dire clairement qu'il faut
que certains Français cotisent 44 ans
non ça veut dire aussi surtout que il
faut faire attention au choix qui sont
faits pour ne pas dégrader la situation
budgétaire de la réforme parce qu'on
peut dire tiens on va donner aux uns aux
autres c'est juste et ça serait
d'ailleurs très légitime mais il faut
garder j'allais dire une pertinence à
cette réforme sinon on va nous dire
écoutez il y a des gens dans la rue ça
passe pas très bien comme à chaque fois
donc si vous faites une réforme qui
n'atteint pas son objectif budgétaire et
qu'on a pas j'allais dire
une soutenabilité en 2030 jusqu'en 2030
on lui dit on attendait à quoi ça sert
donc il faut absolument avoir un cadrage
budgétaire les carrières longues ça
coûte cher ça coûte cher donc il faut
trouver un point d'équilibre je crois
que le point d'équilibre c'est un peu ce
qui a dit mon collègue Savary avant moi
c'est autour des 20-21 ans pour faire je
vais dire claire parce que son des
matières ou c'est très compliqué quand
on met la tête là dedans plus ça va moi
ça va donc il faut s'accrocher aux
branches donc mais le point d'équilibre
c'est pas tout le monde à 43 ans selon
vous
ça veut dire certains 43 certains 44
comme c'est dans le projet comme c'est
écrit dans le projet
la proposition du gouvernement et puis
il y a eu une avancée suite au débat à
l'Assemblée autour des 20 21 ans disant
avant 20 ans 5 trimestres etc puis après
il y a eu un truc où personne comprenait
pas très bien où on disait oui à partir
de 17 ans
peut-être et éventuellement olympions
s'est aperçu que les 18 19 ans c'était
44 à nuités
j'allais dire compliqué c'est que le
gouvernement doit faire un décret c'est
du réglementaire donc il va falloir
qu'on en parle d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
avec la première ministre puisqu'on la
voit à midi
pour lui dire voilà il faudrait qu'on
s'entende pour trouver un point
d'équilibre parce que si on va trop loin
ça va coûter comme dirait les jeunes une
blinde et après on dégrade le
l'aspect budgétaire on va nous dire
pourquoi c'est très fort puisqu'on
pourra plus rien faire d'autre dans cet
état d'esprit là sur le sur le
concernant les femmes Bruno Retailleau
souhaitait une surcote pour les maires
de famille de trois enfants donc sur
quoi tu as 63 ans finalement la mesure
concernera toutes les maires de famille
alors parce que est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec vous est-ce que on est
tombé d'accord et par contre par contre
ça veut dire aussi que ça c'est
typiquement le genre d'avancer entre
guillemets qui qui provoque un surcoût
et de ce que vous venez nous expliquer
c'est que du coup au surco on finira par
avoir une réforme ce sera pas d'économie
mais nos priorités c'était l'équilibre
budgétaire du dispositif parce qu'il
faut avoir une raison de faire cette
réforme 2 et 3 c'était femme et seniors
et des la situation des femmes et
notamment des maires de famille et les
seniors c'était la priorité après il y a
plein d'autres choses
ça c'est votre feuille de route
équilibre financier
les mesures en faveur des femmes et des
mesures pour l'emploi des seniors en un
après il y a d'autres choses il faut
faire des choix on peut pas tout faire
alors niveau 2 c'est vos priorités les
carrières longues et les régimes
spéciaux il y a la pénibilité et il y a
les territoires puisque on aide aussi
les collectivités voilà et pour les
femmes du coup c'est ce sont les
centrices qui ont poussé parce que Bruno
Retailleau au début il voulait que ça
concerne les mères de 3 ans et qui a un
des ou qui a un départ anticipé
ça concerne tout le monde c'est une
préoccupation partagée on s'est mis
d'accord voilà vous souhaitez d'autres
mesures concernant par les deux
rapporteurs Elizabeth Doisneau et et
René Paul ça va vous souhaitez d'autres
mesures concernant les femmes et la
politique familiale en général oui mais
qui ne pourront pas rentrer parce que le
choix fait par le gouvernement c'est
celle d'un collectif budgétaire c'est
une
un plfssr c'est un rectificatif du
budget social qu'on a voté en novembre
donc on peut pas tout mettre là-dedans
sinon on est en soit inconstitutionnel
soit cavalier budgétaire donc il y a
d'autres mesures d'accompagnement qu'on
souhaite mettre dans la loi travail du
printemps que prépare Olivier dussobe
justement en particulier pour
accompagner la réforme des retraites
c'est-à-dire
par exemple tout ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement des familles pour les
enfants les crèches
des aides pour les familles parce que on
nous dit il y a besoin de réforme parce
que il y a pas assez de cotisants parce
que la démographie est pas bonne ça va
pas dans le bon sens
d'ailleurs c'est un sujet européen donc
il faut essayer d'aider les familles
pour que la natalité s'améliore je dis
pas que ça du jour au lendemain les gens
vont avoir des enfants youpi et que tout
va aller mieux mais enfin il faut au
moins qu'on accompagne les familles pour
favoriser la situation il y a aussi une
mesure portée par les centrices
concernant les parents maltraitants vous
souhaitez réduire les pensions des
parents maltraitants
c'est assez incompréhensible que
quelqu'un qui est condamné pour mauvais
traitement ou pour abandon de famille
ils bénéficient de droit à la retraite
grâce à ses enfants un petit paradoxe
quoi
donc il est assez naturel que on puisse
deschoir si je puis dire ceux qui sont
condamnés de leurs droits à pension
puisque ils ont été maltraitants
vis-à-vis de leur famille de leurs
enfants et donc on peut pas les
gratifier de de pension bonifiées
l'autre point vous l'avez dit c'est la
question de l'emploi des seniors alors
vous avez trouvé là aussi un compromis
sur l'index senior puisque ce qui avait
été rejeté à l'Assemblée mais ce qui
était prévu c'était que ça s'applique
aux entreprises de 50 salariés vous
souhaitiez que ça ne s'applique aux
entreprises le 300 salariés pourquoi ce
seuil parce que on voit bien que c'est
quand même une suggestion c'est quand
même de la paperasse c'est quand même du
travail etc des entreprises petites et
moyennes de
50 100 150 salariés ils ont déjà
beaucoup de suggestions administratives
on a pensé que il fallait aller à un
niveau un seuil où il y a déjà une organ
de la DRH on a pensé que 300 qui
correspond à un critère dans le droit du
travail pour des conventions collectives
internes etc soit le bon seuil parce que
300 vous avez une DRH vous avez un
service administratif bon l'index là
aussi un compromis passer avec les
républicains parce qu'il n'est pas très
chaud sur l'index bon
c'est index bah écoutez la CFDT est
favorable à l'index la CPME aussi c'est
il y a un index pour la parité bon je
pense que c'est un indicateur nous on
était
désireux de la sortir d'un bonus malus
c'est à dire de dire il y a l'indicateur
bon déjà il faut le produire donc une
amende pour ceux qui le produisent pas
et parce qu'il faut de la transparence
et puis en même temps aider les
entreprises vertueuses avec une
réfraction de cotisation sociale là
encore on tombe dans l'aspect juridique
on nous dit ah vous pouvez pas mettre ça
là-dedans juridiquement ça marche pas
donc
parce que là encore
ça fait cavalier budgétaire on peut pas
intégrer dans le le véhicule
plfssr une mesure par le biais d'un
autre la fameuse loi travail la fameuse
de travail qui sert un peu de voiture
balai
de la loi retraite quoi est-ce qu'on
peut pas mettre dedans on va pouvoir en
parler mais pas le faire tout de suite
on peut pas
on le voit vous nous dites depuis le
début de cette interview il a fallu
trouver des compromis avec les
républicains vous n'étiez pas forcément
d'accord sur la vision du texte est-ce
que ça a été compliqué de se mettre
d'accord avec les républicains non parce
que encore une fois on avait peut-être
des des propositions qui étaient pas
totalement les mêmes donc on s'est mis
d'accord parce que l'objectif était le
même et dès la situation des femmes et
des seniors et puis regarder les autres
situations donc on a approché et on a
congé il y a que un point
il y en a peut-être d'autres
quelques-uns dans le détail mais il y a
un point où on n'est pas encore
totalement d'accord enfin vous l'avez vu
à travers les propos de René Paul à
l'instant c'est sur les régimes spéciaux
bon alors les régimes spéciaux que les
républicains veulent ils veulent
accélérer leur suppression ils veulent
que ça commence dès 2025 avec un âge
légal à 64 ans en 2040 vous n'êtes pas
du tout favorable
c'est un peu rude
je veux dire que les républicains
veuillent avoir des marqueurs de droite
parce qu'ils disent nous sommes de
droite et donc nous défendons des
propositions de droite pour les
électeurs de droite moi je vois pas
d'inconvénients mais nous on a des
marqueurs au centre on a d'autres
positions et préoccupations et sur les
carrières longues il faudra sûrement
discuter je dis pas que tout est
idyllique enfin il y a une situation des
scènes qu'est-ce que vous proposez de
rester sur le texte du Gouvernement à
savoir la clause du grand-père ça ne
s'applique que aux personnes entre on
est prêt à parler mais je veux dire
il faut regarder ça avec prudence c'est
quand même un sujet qui est quand même
assez explosif il se passe des choses de
cette mars et je pense que les syndicats
envoient bien qui a un front syndical on
voit bien qu'il y a quand même dans la
société une fracture il faut reconnaître
la situation telle qu'elle est à chaque
réforme des retraites il y a
j'allais dire une difficulté forte avec
la prise en considération de la réforme
cette fois-ci c'est assez puissant on
l'a vu bon c'est pas pour autant qu'il
faut pas faire la réforme mais il faut
aborder certains sujets avec une
gouvernement vous êtes plutôt sur la
ligne clause du grand-père on est sur la
ligne close du grand-père nous voilà
après il faut regarder il y a peut-être
des choses à regarder à faire bouger
mais on souhaite le prendre le temps de
le faire et pas se précipiter en ayant
un dogme et en disant il faut absolument
faire comme si parce que c'est aussi
parce que cette question des régimes
spéciaux peut être de nature à remettre
de l'huile sur le feu par rapport à la
contestation sociale
qui font que le centrisme bloqueront
non s'il s'agit pas de bloquer on est
ouvert au dialogue je veux dire encore
une fois ces régimes spéciaux
aujourd'hui on n'a pas trouvé d'accord
bon alors bien on va continuer à parler
et
je désespère pas que qu'on trouve un
point de compromis dans dans les jours à
venir mais aujourd'hui on n'est pas
d'accord bon moi je respecte je veux
dire que Bruno Retailleau et René Paul
Savary soit sur une ligne je la respecte
mais nous on est on n'est pas sur cette
ligne là peux vous qu'est-ce que vous
demandez Elisabeth borde qu'est-ce que
vous allez lui dire à la première
ministre
la première ministre on va lui présenter
nos propositions et on va lui dire voilà
nous on fait pas de surenchères on
essaie pas de faire monter la
température avec des exigences
insupportables je crois qu'on a des
propositions raisonnables qui permettent
justement un équilibre budgétaire on a
quelques priorités je pense pas qu'elle
y soit hostile et donc faut trouver avec
elle les moyens de trouver un terme à
toutes ces propositions
moi je suis confiant dans l'idée qu'elle
abondera et que elle accompagnera le
Sénat pour qu'on aille jusqu'au bout
mais du coup les économies vous allez
les trouver où dans ce texte avec les
propositions que nous avons faites et
sous réserve d'évaluation très précises
parce que là aussi c'est c'est pas c'est
pas très facile je pense qu'on tient une
épure qui
permet de d'abonder jusqu'en 2030 après
je pense que la vraie réforme et le Roi
Lion en 2027 parce qu'il faut on parle
de clause de revoyure en 2027 mais en
2027 il se passe quelque chose ce sont
les élections présidentielles vous
croyez quand même pas que les candidats
en 2027 on va rien leur demander et là
une autre réforme pour vous ça sera plus
une clause
une réflexion au centre de les campagnes
quoi une réflexion
est-ce que cette réforme là n'est qu'une
étape déjà on parle de l'horizon 2030
2031 il y a eu plusieurs réformes avant
la dernière c'est c'est 2010 donc on
voit bien que il faut s'adapter c'est
pour ça qu'on souhaite qu'il y a une
clause d'envoyeur mais il se trouve
qu'en 2027 c'est aussi les élections
présidentielles donc il faudra faire un
point d'étape si je puis dire et puis
les candidats je suis convaincu auront
leur proposition c'est à dire qu'ils
diront bah écoutez il faut arrêter la
répartition faut passer à la
capitalisation ou d'autres diront non il
faut revenir à l'idée de
la réforme par point qu'avait esquissé
Édouard Philippe d'autres diront non pas
du tout faut rester là la réforme Papin
c'est un sujet qui est plus juste un
sujet de 2027 ouais ça fait partie des
réflexions structurelles de 2027 c'est
pour ça qu'on souhaite pas en parler
maintenant quand je vois des amendements
pour la capitalisation déjà
que il faut s'accrocher aux branches
pour comprendre
les tenants et aboutissants toutes les
mesures si on commence à dire tiens on
va parler de capitalisation du point
alors là il y a plus personne qui va
capter en attendant 2027 le futur
immédiat du la réforme et de ce texte
c'est quoi qu'est-ce qui va se passer
donc admettons les sénateurs arrivent à
aller au bout du texte il est voté
ensuite il y a une commission mix
paritaire il y a vous pensez qu'il y
aura un accord sur un texte commun et
c'est c'est terminé à votre conclusif et
la réforme état d'optée je pense que de
toute façon il y aura une réforme
bonne ou mauvaise qu'on le veuille ou
qu'on le veuille pas parce que le
gouvernement et le président de la
République je pense peuvent pas reculer
[Musique]
à ce point
pour aucun moment donné on dit ah bah
finalement bah écoutez c'est compliqué
on va ranger tout ça on verra ça ce qui
s'est passé en 2020 oui en 2020 la
réforme avait été adoptée par 49-3 on
aurait pu elle est toujours sur le
bureau du Sénat d'ailleurs on aurait pu
la sortir du tiroir sauf que hop terminé
bon ça aurait été facile mais
toujours est-il que aujourd'hui
il n'y a pas les mêmes le même contexte
quand avec Édouard Philippe Édouard
Philippe il avait fait sa réforme en
disant justement on n'a pas besoin de
faire de réformes on a le temps c'est
justement le moment de la faire
maintenant on a besoin de faire la
réforme on a plus le temps donc parce
que il y a un problème budgétique
je pense que le gouvernement s'il arrive
pas à obtenir un vote passera par le
49-3 pour vous c'est pas un problème si
c'est un problème mais je pense qu'il ne
pourra pas reculer mais en tout état de
cause ça ira au bout
un dernier mot sur le 7 mars puisque ça
sera en pleine examen de la réforme au
Sénat vous redoutez cette journée vous
redoutez des blocages
j'étais important il faut le reconnaître
ils étaient aussi responsables calme il
y a pas eu de débordements faut saluer
l'action des des syndicats et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que nous on souhaite
une conférence sociale parce que cette
réforme a été l'occasion de mettre en
évidence les le rôle des syndicats qui
sont un peu réhabiliter jusqu'à présent
il y a beaucoup de verticalité on a un
des points de l'action de Monsieur
Macron ça a été justement de tuer un peu
le paritarisme de tuer de dialogue
social et le dialogue avec les corps
intermédiaires on fait des travaux
j'allais dire par segment on fait
l'indemnisation du chômage on fait les
retraites après on vous dit il va y
avoir une loi travail on travaille sur
le pouvoir d'achat et pourquoi on fait
pas une grande conférence sociale pour
parler de tout ça il y a une société
post covid le travail plus même la façon
d'appréhender la société n'est plus la
même et les syndicats sont en pointe
regardez monsieur Attal il fait des
propositions pour dire tiens on va
regarder si on peut travailler 4 jours
bon enfin tout ça on peut pas en parler
parce qu'il y a un problème plutôt que
de faire des débats comme ça par-ci
par-là
on voit que le Renaissance dans un coin
il travaille sur le partage de la valeur
parce que il voit bien qu'il y a un
sujet que bon on peut pas on peut pas
sur la table et dire écoutez la société
a évolué les syndicats ont des
propositions le gouvernement aussi
travaillons sérieux devant les boeufs en
fait il aurait fallu faire la seule
conférence sociale avant la réforme
normalement
Stéphane l'industrie automobile cherche
son sursaut journal merci Stéphane merci
beaucoup Hervé Marseille on continue à
parler de cette réforme des retraites
dans le club